do you have regrets that you didn't stay
in school because now like I I didn't
pay attention in school I mean I went to
college and everything but I didn't and
I look back on my education now there's
these huge gaps in my education and I
fantasize now because I do love to learn
and I take all kinds of online courses
and stuff don't you fantasize that you
would have taken advantage of that time
period and really gone to school and
gone to town with everything well here's
the thing is I I the moment I quit
school I kept up uh my self-education I
pretty much to this day especially about
the stuff that I care about right the
thing the thing that was sad about me
quitting school
I mean look there's a big bragging
notion about the fact that I mean I
didn't even quit High School I quit
Middle School right yeah and to actually
be become a success later that's like a
lot of cool bragging rights makes me
looks even smarter right yeah but and
also I think a lot of people go hey he
quit school I can quit school and I'll
be a big film director you know he's
also a genius you know but that's your
thought though so what was the what was
the thing that you know the thing that
the thing that's sad is when you quit in
the ninth grade you don't understand
anything about college I actually
literally thought in the ninth grade
that school would be exactly like it's
gonna like it was then forever well in a
way no one explained the world to you
either you didn't have a father who
explained it your mother was probably
busy working her ass she was actually
yeah and you know so the thing is it
would have been great to have a college
experience it would have been a great to
go away meet all the people that you
meet in school and all that that whole
so the whole social and learning aspect
of it how does a guy with such limited
education become a screenwriter I mean
you I know you tried to be an actor for
a while then all of a sudden when you go
to acting class uh they'd say hey this
thing you wrote is really good and you
it started to Dawn on you that you were
a better writer and director than you
were perhaps an actor how do you know
how to even in that format know how to
write a screenplay did you study
screenplays and screenplay writing oh
yeah I I was actually literally writing
screenplays in school or you know those
little ABC after school specials I'd
come up with some story and I'd be that
that would be what I was doing in school
I'd be doing my own writing and my own
stuff not the schoolwork
foreign